on two three and this is a message for
Tony Abbott we're here with our gives us
four three simple things and the first
is that twenty-eight quality of live in
the media to have a short conversation
if he does that five of us will be
allowed to go we can't understand what
that hasn't happened the second is that
he wants the politicians to announce the
truth which is that this is an attack by
Islamic state on Australia and if that
something two of us will be allowed to
go and the third is that he wants an
Islamic state flare to live it to us
here and then he goes if you do that
then one of us will be allowed to go
look it up dude
this is a message to Tony Abbott we're
how do you hostage the bowler has three
requests one is for him to get an is
flag and you will release one hostage
the second one is for the media to
inform the other brothers not to exfolia
other two bombs which are also in the
city there are four bombs all together
here and the third our request is for
Tony Abbott's you contact the brother
via live web somehow and he will release
five hostages villains then why these
demands have been met yet they are not
unreasonable he's only asking for a flag
and a phone call and that's it